another banger from the twitter account
bad legal takes
someone from abc was asking to use a
video clip that was taken on a plane to
which another person
helpfully responds them asking was a
formality once you post something on the
internet it's out there for the world to
see and use as they please without
having to pay or ask for your
authorization to use legally they just
have to credit the person who recorded
and posted
no look this is a common misconception
about copyright law but it is
very very wrong when things enter the
public domain yes you can use them for
any purpose but for something to enter
the public domain they basically need to
have their copyright term
expired that generally means they have
to be 100 or 120 years old just because
something is
public doesn't mean it's in the public
domain just because something is on the
internet doesn't mean you can use it for
whatever reason you want
don't do that if you use stuff that's on
the internet without getting the proper
rights
i will see you in court